behindert an einigen springt geschrieben
hallo ich werde die freunde herzlich
willkommen zu einer folge dna zusammen
mit angel feld nils 10 11 keks cookie
keks und hat mit allen außer mit sturm
waffel hier alle weg
ich hoffe ich auch weggekickt ja alle
weg werden wir so eine schöne ändert
alle mieter also erst mal guten tag
sturm waffe und ich hab mal ganz kurz
sagen dass das ganze eigentlich zu der
uhrzeit jetzt gerade sollte eine
einstündige galaxy folge kommen weil du
weißt es ja auch wenn man keine leistung
machen kann dann kann man ja eine lange
fall gemacht
bei mir ist es allerdings gerade so dass
nach meiner letzten folge wo auch mein
ton weg war lag wohl nicht alle der city
sondern lag einfach daran dass galaxy
beendet wurde und das hat ihm wie fritz
mit den tod gerissen und auch mein oder
city und dann ist jetzt mein lounge auch
noch kaputt und alles ist im eimer ich
weiß ich was man beim pc los ist
jedenfalls muss das alles neu machen und
da ich jetzt gerade wenn ihr das video
seht den ganzen tag weg bin weil ich bin
am nürburgring ein 24 stunden lang
gucken
jedenfalls kann mich den ganzen tag
keine zeitung irgendwas zu machen
deswegen hoffe ich dass euch das reicht
das ist nämlich noch unter dna und
strommast und helm auf hab ich nicht das
inferno waffeln
das wechsel-thema das stört mich ein
bisschen den a7 sondern einfach mal
reingehen einer kirche ist ok magazine
stimmt daher heißt einer genauso wie du
ja das ist dem kind nicht nur er liegt
ganz fertig so süchtig ist sich schnell
klären
ja mach mal wenn die zeitgleich
abgelaufen ist hast du einen lesern den
gefährten gläsernen block im inventar
und den musst du dann suchen da drauf
springen und wenn du dann auf deinem
blog bis macht es immer dinge genau
jetzt in der countdown kommt dann kommt
ein neuer blog auf dem musste dann auch
drauf springen und so weiter und so fort
und du kannst natürlich also du musst
kein ziel ist es halt ganz weit nach
oben zu kommen
ja also genau dann springt sie von blog
zu blog und du kannst die blöcke
natürlich auch abspeichern
das heißt wir nur auf einen drauf stehst
kannst du einfach indem du auf dem blog
wird rechts oder links klickt klickst
blog halt abspeichern
das heißt weil falls herunterfallen
solltest du immer wieder auf diesen blog
dass er cool und ein bisschen unruhig
bin hier auf einen block drauf und
ich kann quasi gar mehr weiterspielen
weil er so ein anderer blog in der
tasche ist ein noch mal runter also
energie noch mal runter dann müsste es
auch neuen kriegen warte jetzt jetzt
habe ich jetzt gerade genau das im
prinzip das ganze spiel
zu bedenken ist aber wenn um so
eröffneten speichern umso länger dauert
das bis die blöcke kommen
das heißt wenn du sehr häufig speicher
ist dementsprechend hengste dann da am
ende und muss immer so eine minute auf
dem blog warten natürlich nicht so ganz
gut okay gut ich hab jetzt abgespeichert
und jetzt springe ich mal so ein
bisschen ich habe es erst mal noch
gespart und der kamera als relativ
schnell macht mal was gemacht dass dann
ist schon da merkt man es deutlich ich
habe schon sechs punkte
oha damit welche 19 die gehen richtig
abhebt die sind ganz flink aber sagen
ich spiele zum ersten mal der richtige
für mich immer kacke
weißt du wenn ich solche ausweich runden
bringe wenn nicht so wenn eigentlich
etwas cooles plan so kündigt das an und
daher ist es gerade so aber ja das
kannst du dafür betragen
ich kann ja nichts dafür das ist halt
wirklich einfach oder ich habe da etwas
kaputt gemacht ich bin mir gar nicht
sicher vielleicht habe ich da wirklich
etwas falsch gemacht und dann hast mich
jetzt auf einmal alles und alles hat
sich gelöscht und wann hat man gewonnen
die auf stufe 32 dies sollen diese
länder sollen da wo die lichter sind auf
der höhe
veranlasst ihren säulen zu riechen
die ändern soll ja verstehen nämlich
auch den main kräftig sparen muss ich
weiß nicht wohin soll da ich spreche
jetzt hier ab ich bin offen ich bin
schon zufrieden bin ich schon auf zehn
nicht höher als ich und du bist ja ich
auch irgendwie geraten ist ein verfahren
ein hoffen wie oft ich sehe dich sehe
ich guck mal ich hab mich umbenannt hier
ich bin der hier der hypo was kriegst
dass ihr wieso hab ich nicht so schnell
war wie so wenige sind manchmal wenn die
wenn die blöcke so blinken
was waren die schnell jetzt besser wie
gemacht ich habe es bisher elf geschafft
wie sowie die gamer noch besuchen es
sollte nie so lange dauern
es gibt manchmal blinken die blöcke so
und wenn du darauf ist und special
leitung da gibt es dann jumps oder so
eine wie das andere leute sagt ja ich
bin geschäftsmann der chef wieder los
da kommen wir neue leute reif für mich
wo bin ich denn ich war ein herr und ich
bin der lobby
ich muss einfach mal / lobby aber mir
steht angeht
ich bin gerade in der lobby wo bin ich
dann moment wird mir geht gar nix hier
wenig auf lobby clique manchmal manchmal
/ lobby einfach nochmal / lobby sprich
in der lobby
jetzt geht's los hier bin ich und du ich
komm jetzt hin
ok superstars mit diesen da ich denn die
lobby wechseln könnte bei den magic hat
auch nichts mit dem okay der mama /
lobby
wir haben hier auch schon heute geht
auch noch nicht offiziell lobby 32 war
eigentlich steht übrigens in der
beschreibung als erstmal selbst spielen
wird
da stehen also bis zum 3 ich komme ich
komm ich komm tatsächlich ich dich
das war in den a 10 oder ok ja ich bin
den 10
ich weiß nicht wie mein nam ändern ich
heiße jetzt laut biskind von von manuel
vom produkt namens ehrlich bin wolfskin
ok cool oder juli sind herzlich
willkommen
christ wieder staffel hd das ist inferno
waffel
er guckt ja den geilen skin in zürich
statt 34 sekunden kommentieren
so kommentiert mein letztes leute
springen
ich hab das glas wichtig ist dass in
nicht mal bin ich selbst mal den ersten
platz auf zwei und den safe ich erst mal
gehört was antwort nicht reden hier die
ganze sein hallo leider keins map
denn trotz die wollen ja nur ihre arbeit
machen weniger spaß beträgt wir dann war
da nicht über zwei gekommen
fleckiger spaß mit lollipop ag wo ich
springe gucken sie zu michael porr ag
für alle sind lange springe ich bin das
opfer ich bringe 6,2 zurück statt 000
zugriffe als letzter wie kann man denn
nun schaffen stellen das mal vor du bist
nicht was erstens er sich nur auf der
ersten lok aufgekommen mittendrin
meldete sich so am besten fand ich
schreibe so ich schätze dass ich denke
ich hätte zugriff stall hallo fremdlack
und dann also high oder zuschauer so hey
lass ich sagen hallo ich heiße drei
sagte heil
behinderte erneut alle stehen auf dna
als im alten team street gut darin
lachmuskel total weh gefallen hat das
mit einer bewertung sturm waffe ist
scheiße wer es in der beschreibung
verlinkt und zugriff stahl maschinen
youtube kanal hat mich lieber nachgucken
oder so schaue ich dass shell jetzt
einfach alle von der plattform eines lp
genommen
tut mir leid dass heute kein galaxy
kamen morgen kommt es dafür wieder wenn
ich das alles wieder gebacken kriegen
bis dahin und das sagt man
bis zum nächsten mal bis zunächst mal
sagt alles